manuel bajorquez is also on surfside at
a reunification center where families
have been waiting for updates manuel
good morning
good morning jerica as soon as people
learned about the disaster and that
there was a family reunification center
well of course they all rushed over here
looking to one
hopefully see their relatives or if not
at least get some answers about their
whereabouts all their hopes right now
are with those rescue workers
who have been in the rubble overnight
looking for any sign
of those 99 people who remain
unaccounted for it is work that will
likely take
several days but we met one family that
says
they're not ready to give up hope yet
i just want my mom like i i want to go
back a day
and change everything 65 year old judy
spiegel was in the champlain tower south
condo building
when it collapsed and remains
unaccounted for we spoke with her
husband and three children who are
praying for a miracle
i guess we're just really thankful for
all the hard work of the police and fire
and ems services that are out there
continuing to search for that they
continue to push and not give up
and we hope to find some answers and we
hope
to see my mom we just want to see your
mom
they described judy as a dedicated wife
mother
and grandmother earlier you had
described her as your best friend
which is interesting i don't know that
all people would describe their mothers
as their best friend
i think we all would we all would these
are all our best friends
judy's husband kevin was out of town
when the building collapsed
the hardest thing that we're going to do
over the next day or two is
tell right scarlett
my grandma that's the hardest thing
because she was their life
and he was there for them day and night
she gave herself to everybody
and no matter what happens i want
everybody in the world to know
how wonderful my mom is and how much how
great of a person she
is and how much we love her and she
loves us
and you know whatever happens like
i'm committed to
keeping her alive in every sense of the
way
and just think for a second about all
the families that are experiencing
that type of heartbreak right now as you
heard
they talked about how difficult it will
be to tell her grandchildren about this
she was such a doting grandmother
she had just purchased a dress for one
of her granddaughters purchased it
online
it's on its way and they just wish she
could be here to see her
try it on tony oh boy manny that's one
family story but as you mentioned there
are potentially
99 other family stories almost exactly
like it thank you very much